hey everybody welcome to the 13th
episode of 13 o'clock we're back Metta
yes yeah so what's it about well because
it's the 13th episode we thought we
would do kind of a little special
edition kinda I guess because it's 13
and 13 and we were gonna do one about
creepy superstitions yeah and I don't
know anything about the topic tonight no
Jenny did all the work I'm just gonna
sit back and just ride along like I'm at
like like I'm in the audience and maybe
throw a my two senses and also I should
be pointed out I know that you guys
can't um see us cuz we're not on video
but Tom shaved his head yeah ball he's
bald as a cue ball and put that shine on
it yes guys I'm gonna I'll take a
picture and I'll put it in the YouTube
JC you can see here a lot mr. clean I
had to press reset it's foxy okay all
right so anyway we're talking about I
mean specifically we're talking about
creepy superstitions but mostly we're
talking about death omens not imagine
you dug up a lot of pretty good that's
right yeah there are a lot all right
tell me what you found and weirdly I
mean okay the thing about superstitions
it's pretty obvious why people have them
and have had them all throughout history
I mean people don't have that much
control over their lives or as much
control as they'd like to think they do
so you know believing that you know
carrying a rabbit's foot or not doing
you know not walking under a ladder
something like that makes you feel
better it makes you feel like you have
some control that you don't actually
have um so it was like OCD yeah it is
kind of okay it is kind of so you can
see why throughout history you know why
people have had these particular
superstitions now the thing is that some
of them that are really old and really
deep-seated kind of the reasons for them
have been lost to history so we don't
really know why because I mean some of
them it's kind of obvious why people
would have associated certain things
with other things but some of them are
just kind of out there and I don't
really
no I [ __ ] why I OCD made him up that
would be very funny hey why do you do
that because it's bad luck if I make you
fight if I don't do it yeah it's like
something uh somebody with OCD would say
well yeah it's the same kind of might be
like catches on yeah if it's like an
ignorant I'm in the past you know when
there was a lot of ignorance ya know
maybe maybe somebody with OCD would be
seen as an authority yeah you know
because it's like yeah that's oh yeah it
crossed my path that's bad
don't go underneath that ladder although
not going underneath the ladder I think
pretty much common sense yeah so we can
drop something on your lateral although
that one actually goes back I think from
what I've read I think that one goes
back to the ancient Egyptians and it was
actually something to do with don't walk
through like a triangle because that was
sacred
all right blah blah make sense but even
though nowadays it seems just like smart
cuz you know something I'll fall you
know you'll knock the ladder down or
you'll knock the ladder down of that
yeah so it seems like cuz like I said
some of them sprout from things that
were probably just common sense right
and then it just got kind of got refill
turd through like a magical thinking
sort of thing but actually you can see
why some of them seem to be about
witchcraft yeah that all yeah what kind
of like you know a thing where a
representation of a thing is like the
like the bigger thing it looks like a
man so therefore it is a man like some
kind of root like the root yeah like the
yet what does that Mandrake yeah
Mandrake root there you go I can
remember them a bit okay
man Mandrake yeah so you know like I
said want to do death omens because
obviously death is something that is a
pretty universal human fear and you can
see why there are so many omens about
them I kind of what I kind of did was I
just wrote down a bunch of ones and like
in different themes with kind of the
most obvious ones first um you know
because because they're death omens
obviously most of the ones are gonna be
about graveyards about funeral
processions about corpses things like
that and you can see where a lot of
these came from there are a lot of ones
about say walking past two graveyards
and trying to prevent spirits from
following you home yeah um that would be
kind of a logical fear which is kind of
a logical fear I see a graveyard maybe
they see me they following me and some
of these are kind of obvious like I took
almost like a childhood fear yeah okay
it's kind of an obvious thing like you
can see why people why there's a
superstition that when you're walking
past a graveyard you should hold your
breath you don't want to breathe in
because you don't want to breathe the
spirits in yeah sure
now what I think is really cute what I
think is really cute it is there is also
a superstition that when you're walking
past a graveyard you should turn your
pockets inside out so the spirits don't
ride home in your pockets Wow where did
that's where does that come time in
place was that I don't know that's like
a pretty I think that's like some parts
of old Americana
okay you know what I mean I have heard
that one before and I'm from the south
but I just did something about that's
really cute to me like well that's just
it comes in that's a focused version of
yes it goes that you did really find any
documentation on that particular one
well it's just one that was mentioned
over Frank yeah alright and there's also
one that's Japanese where when you're
walking past Cranberries supposed to
tuck your thumbs into your into your
fist yeah because that's supposed to
protect your parents because for some
reason in Japan your thumb is your
parent finger huh symbolizes that's like
yeah it symbolizes your parents so
you're supposed to like kind of protect
them know when you're walking by so they
don't so they don't die so they don't
die it's not so much you dying but yeah
also there's always and this is another
one kind of along the same lines of the
breathing one pregnant women they tell
pregnant women not to go to funerals
because the spirit will hop into your
fetus there was what damn that's pretty
carnation yeah what if it's a cool
person though yeah that's what I mean
it's like in some ways you're almost
like [ __ ] on the person yeah good
thing I don't want you to come out my
baby [ __ ] that imagine Elvis's funeral
you have all millions of pregnant
everybody gonna be on my LV yeah yeah
they'll be like these neon signs
pointing at the belly Joe Pitt here man
I'm bad you know targets I know baby
will come out I almost did it out of a
super I wanna say that it's been a long
time since I've water deserve and you
know you'd have to buy a little sequin
jumpsuit for the baby I mean you know
that would just be obligatory yeah world
was just a stage okay now so there's
also the kind of thing like I said where
the representation of something becomes
the real something so they always tell
you it's a very very bad luck to
participate in a mock funeral or climb
into a coffin while you're still alive
okay
because obviously you know there's also
a lot of one's about curses and these
are usually like one you should never
look at your reflection in the window of
a hearse because I guess that means oh
you're in there all right
and you shouldn't pass in front of one
like if it's in a funeral procession and
also here's one it's kind of weird and
this is an American one and I've heard
this one too so it's southern US at
least I don't know if it's other parts
too but if a hearse is coming toward you
and it's empty then that's good luck
okay but if it's going away from you and
it's empty then that's bad luck okay so
it's coming down the street you think it
would be the other way coming to get you
this is you're standing in the street
here comes a hearse right yeah you got
Sam T it's a good luck yeah because they
want to pick yet either way yeah I saw
her run it is going oh yeah so which is
it I don't know also they tell you that
if you see a funeral procession you
should never count the cars yeah because
that's counting the time till your own
death okay
I don't know why you'd count the cars
anyway but just don't you know don't do
it just to be on the safe side also in
cemeteries and this is a pretty common
one this is
common a lot of cultures where they bury
the dead with their feet point in East
at least in the West they do okay and
most people have thought that that's
probably because you know when Judgment
Day comes in the judeo-christian
mythology I've heard this one then then
you'll be facing the sunrise so you'll
be able to go and you know get up and be
like honey yeah right we're going to
wherever I don't know where you going
but makes it easier to see Jesus when he
comes down yeah tribulation then yeah
yeah but what was that what was actual
terminology of that man I know I used to
know stuff so well it's a rapture yeah
which isn't specifically stated in the
New Testament yeah that was later
invention you have to read in the
rapture into it yeah yeah that's kind of
a later invention right
but um yeah so there's other ones about
funeral processions don't carry a baby
in a funeral procession that means it
will die before its first birthday um
don't leave graves open overnight or on
a Sunday mm-hmm which seems you know cuz
somebody could fall in there you don't
know if you're at a funeral when the
casket slips while it's being lowered or
if you leave if you're the first to
leave the cemetery then that means
you're next
whoa which kind of sucks because
sometimes I just yeah but he has to so
everyone has to stay there everyone just
says not even one victim leave no you
leave no you leave I'm staying here this
is an American one yeah well some of
these these are from all over the world
most of them are Western American or
European there were a few uh Japanese
Chinese sauce in there too but um yeah
so that's kind of funny
so also if the grave is still open and
it starts to rain into the grave that's
bad luck for a family member of the
deceased person they also tell you don't
point at a grave or step on it yeah
which you know that seems just
respectful I guess now all these do now
these are prime
difficult to pinpoint the time and the
place and where these things actually
came yeah yeah they're just kind of like
and I mean sell it alleged it doesn't
really seem like a lot of them I mean a
lot of the ones that I found cuz I kind
of went all over like looking for
different ones a lot of them kind of
came from Victorian England or around
from that time period and then we're
kind of transferred over here right but
every time on their hands I guess and
you know they were so I guess death was
such an omnipresent yeah you know in a
way that we can't really understand that
way like horror novels - they did so
maybe they just sit around and these uh
you know cold dark kind of creepy
apartments and houses and wonder about
what it was like to die and oh boy you
know reading into this and that you know
yeah that's got to be bad luck that
doesn't seem right yeah seemed like they
were kind of into that like Geograph and
dead babies and they were morbid
they were morbid yeah I mean I'm sure
not they all were but that's kind of the
oppression this it's like I'm morbid to
I can't really say anything about it I
guess they were you know face to face
death on a daily basis with reason I
mean it's kind of like trying to
rationalize and come to terms with it I
mean nowadays I mean at least in this
part of the world were kind of removed
from it yeah I mean obviously everyone
dies and I'm suppose you don't really
it's not like they sit in your house
yeah so it seemed like a lot of the ones
about corpses and mirrors and things
like that kind of stem from that time
period when they would have like a few
days of the corpse still in the house
and it's fine that modern people kind of
look back at the Victorian age and you
would think that was kind of like this
period it was kind of peaceful ah oh
yeah those look at the crime scene
photos from the day and they were taking
crime scene photos yeah gross
well yeah yeah they were business back
then at least they some of them were
well yeah there was a lot of horrible
[ __ ] going on back then and I mean we
saw like I said when we did the show
about the the serial killers the
prisoners a lot of that was 18 a lot of
that was was that time period same as
Jack the Ripper that kind of you
late 19th century they'd have these
cameras on a tripod they'd set it up
over the body and it would take a photo
straight down on that dead body there's
a lot of them online you can look at him
I mean you know people's with their
heads bashed in yeah
people chopped up with axes and it's in
and it went down in some creepy
Victorian apartment or house you're like
what a hell happened there bet you a lot
of that stuff unsolved well yeah they
don't really have the you know forensic
technology to really solve anything you
kind of had to just see it happen and
they're like okay you're under arrest
right I mean it's not like they're gonna
really find out later but uh not a team
time no no and it it's funny because in
a lot of ways I think modern people are
like oh you used to be so much better
back in the day I'm like now I think
it's a lot better now I'm really aware
of what was going on yeah yeah yeah I
mean now now it's more of an information
flow yeah so it seems like you're
assaulted with bad [ __ ] all the time but
they were assaulted with bad [ __ ] they
did yeah according to the photographs I
saw yeah there are also ones about
corpses don't carry a body in your own
vehicle which I don't know why I would
do that but shortage of horses back then
maybe yeah just put mod in the back log
back there well lampoon's vacation where
they was it their grandmother their
aunts or whoever like died on the road
trip and they strapped her to the top
that's what it made me think of that or
weekend at Bernie's we were that guy
there basta and there pretended he was
still alive whatever you're in stories
of guys taking their buddies to the bar
they're dead buddies to the bar for a
few drinks but yeah but yeah heard of
that that was 1807 that's yeah see
that's gonna take him out here we'd do
that now like if you did that now and be
like brah yeah they'd call the cops
yes [ __ ] you did take him down for a
final drink man popping up on the bar we
buy him drinks and put pour drinks down
his throat then yeah baby like
weirdos man they were yeah they are in a
lot of ways they dressed awesome though
I got it yeah very goth okay more one's
about corpses this and this is a very
common one corpses when you're carrying
them out of the house again Victorian
you should always carry them out feet
first yeah evidently this is because I
guess if their head is still lingering
in the house then they're like that's
like a come-hither thing like I'm
bringing other people with me into death
that is also why they closed the corpses
eyes because you're not supposed to look
at a corpse right in the eye and I've
stuck you in it might suck you in oh
yeah look because he's looking for
followers I got and ostensibly some
sources say that this is why they
started putting coins on the eyes yeah
although there's some other like some
people said oh because of the the
ferryman of the rivers fried hair out or
whatever is wrong Sharon and that was or
in Christian tradition it's you know to
pay st. Peter I guess that's the heaven
cover charge
right okay so also if there is a dying
person your house and and your name is
the last name they say then you are now
you're a goner which sucks because it
seems like that would be a really common
thing like if somebody's dying in their
house and you're their spouse or their
family member or whatever and they just
go yeah by Tom yeah and then and then
you'd be like Bob see something else you
[ __ ] say someone else's name someone
you don't know she's it could be anybody
Harold I don't know sorry Harold this
one is also kind of funny if a dying
person hits or bites you then you will
be the next to die unless you hit or
bite them back for next in the same
place like you know I mean you have to
get a buddy buddy it wonder where that
kid and I was like well I guess I'm the
walking dead that's true if a dying
person writes you yeah you are the next
to go so that was that one was pretty
prescient
also this one's kind of obvious clothes
of a living person should never be used
to dress a dead person yeah now this one
this is probably my favorite one of the
whole thing now if someone is murdered
mm-hm and if they're if the their
intestines after they're dead if their
intestines after they're dead Rumble oh
that means I mean if someone touches
them in their intestines Rumble that
means that's the person that killed them
what yeah man man being convicted of
that I know just some gasp yes some
intestinal gas accessible gassing the
corpse farted and it's like well you're
off to the gallery right yeah
and also I'm stand up in court probably
well back then it probably what I think
it will everybody been like yeah sounds
legit and there's a couple other ones
like that also if the corpses nose
bleeds
that means the murderer is in the room
means you did it that means you did it
and or if blood comes out of the bones
even if the corpse is old like even if
it's a skeleton yeah yeah I didn't know
blood could come out of those scales it
can't okay yeah well that's probably why
that superstition held on because it
never happened right it's like they
could just pretend that it was sure have
a good eye on those bones yeah cuz you
never know blood is leaking out of there
too
yeah and that also means the same thing
if the corpses limp for a long time like
if it doesn't get rigor mortis then that
means that someone else in the house is
going to die soon and also and you can
kind of see threads of this one still
evidently if you touch a corpse that
keeps the spirit of the person from
haunting you for some reason I guess
you're just going chill bro you know
don't don't come after me right and if
you touch them on the forehead that
means you won't dream about them like as
a dead person you'll have nightmares
about them okay and this is also this is
another murder one if a person was
murdered you're supposed to bury them
facedown right to keep the murderer from
leaving the area what how does that work
I don't know see ya
so I guess somehow the corpse being
faced to help it keeps the person from
kill them from leaving like it makes
like a little psychic
fence around the area yeah some reason
that I can't leave I don't know why yeah
it's like they get to it's like it's
like that dog fence that's like
invisible and it gets the anything it's
like it's Ito things under the dome
that's a dumb it is and and it doesn't
make any sense I qui I can lady I can
see how like I know some cultures bury
corpses face down or or like up right to
keep the corpse from getting up and
walking away I can understand that many
I think was face down turned into a
vampire that became a vampire they would
just continue to do dig down that's what
I mean so that's you know it's dumb
still but you can understand the logic
behind this one I don't understand the
logic of a corpse being face down making
someone else not be able to move around
freely I don't get that magical thinking
and there's another one to that you're
supposed to if a person's murdered
you're supposed to bury the bodies
separate from the liver huh because the
person that murdered the person will be
caught near where the liver is buried
because I guess they're a drawn by the
liver power of the dead person see these
ones I don't really like I said these
are ones that these are American no
these are these are that's European I
bet you this year doesn't do European
but yeah I don't get that I don't get
how they got from point A to point
that's on that witchcraft is fired like
I said a lot of these you can see the
logic behind them yes I can see d-type
logic yeah because you know how people's
brains work I don't at me I'm gonna go
to get sucked into the that's totally I
can understand that that's totally yeah
that's not I'm not gonna say it's
reasonable but you can understand where
they're coming from because they
understand the feeling behind it yeah
exactly
that's what I mean also a woman should
never be buried wearing black because
she will come back to haunt the family I
thought they buried him in black a lot I
did to you oh wait a minute wait a
minute I'm trying to think of some of
the Victorian Dead funeral photos death
was I think they weren't all white yeah
sure I think a lot of different bride
yeah I have to do you may be right yeah
they were where does all right I mean
I'm not saying like we're we're old
Goths you know so this were the last
person that became beena
casting aspersions on other
was fired a lot by Victoria oh yeah and
I still love a lot of that [ __ ] like I
said there were fantastic dressers I'm
sure they smelled really bad back in the
day but yeah we can still wear all their
cool shake with gasoline in their hair
yeah yeah yeah mmm
Henry Ford put motor oil in his hair it
wasn't the same water oil yeah it's not
you know it didn't stick it didn't stink
like it didn't that wasn't a synthetic
my true you could cook food in a motor
oil in those days and they did it they
fried food well then they wash clothes
in it too didn't they dry cleaning -
well Matt dry cleaning obviously because
it's a fluid but you know what I mean
same kind of thing um an old guy I
worked with you it was a long time ago
and he was probably 85 back then I was
the only guy ever knew that deep fried a
chicken in motor oil back back a long
time ago though
yeah old fashioned motor oil he said
there was no other flavor like that and
it was absolutely delicious that was
better than peanut oil or Crisco or and
they said it just gave it evidently
because of the viscosity of old motor
oil yeah
it caused a seal around your batter yeah
kept all the moisture inside and the oil
wouldn't penetrate the batter okay
evidently pretty sad he said it was
delicious but that was before they had
detergents and stuff right and and and
all the additives the aunt of the what
he called the anti friction yeah I had
it if they didn't have you that back
then and I think the time he was talking
about must have been the 40s or the 30s
yeah and when he was a kid oh yeah it
was great it was delicious
I was looking like a second oh no
offence steady old people as old people
are listen to this and I'm out that
generation is all gone man and and
they're all dead now they're 20 by now
I'm sure I'm kind of like look askance
at their tasted food because yeah if you
look at some of the stuff they a back
that I don't know
hotdog casserole on jelly yeah oh yeah
let me let me give a shout-out right
here to a website called gallery of
regretable food go back and read that it
is hole air I cried laughing that food
is atrocious
yeah great that was oh yeah okay so
anyway death Romans okay so if there's a
person and they're in a house and
they're dying and lightning strikes
their house that means the devil has
come to claim them hmm
and also if a person's mouth and eyes
are open when they die that means
they're going to hell no [ __ ] for some
reason there'd be around to close that
mouth and the eyes real quick with you
that's what I mean I was like yes the
Devils coming here comes the lightning
it's almost Merkel oh actually it is
[ __ ] okay so we've been so we're gonna
what well how many more death ones do
you have um that's kind of that's kind
of an end of the well they're all death
omens but those are that's the end of
the graveyard funeral corpse thing and
now we're going to like other stuff okay
commercials so okay so we're gonna take
a break and we'll be right back in just
a minute ladies and gentlemen erotic
Entertainment Network presents
is the greatest manager of all time
mando Guerrero parts unknown
up-and-coming superstar if you're into
cosplay Corsa tree
steampunk gothic or rockabilly clothing
shoes and accessories then you must
visit subculture corsets and clothing
either online at www.haddadtoyota.com
code 13 o'clock and receive a 10%
discount on your entire order and if
you're a full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carries sizes 4 through 4x
and they have men's clothing as well
that's subculture corsets calm and use
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount go check out their website now
subculture corsets calm or when
traveling through Jacksonville Florida
stop in and check out their store at the
Avenues Mall watch out there's a new
terror taking over kitchens around the
world
thrills chills mad cooking skills it
cooks a weekly podcast brimming with
recipes tips food fights seasonal
specials and guests galore hosted by
horror author amber Fallon hey that's me
a foodie with over 20 years experience
cooking bacon and generally making a
nuisance of herself you've watched Food
Network you've read cookbooks but
nothing can prepare you for it cooks
coming to a device near you okay we're
back talking about death omens and
creepy superstitions about death since
this is our 13th episode yeah and we
thought that would be neat and here's
kind of a common thing that's usually
very bad luck and I'm sure this is
probably pretty much just a Western
thing you know it's called the rule of
three and you can see that with the
mistaken assumption that celebrities die
in groups of three it seems like they do
but they don't really um three on a
match have you heard that one that's a
very very common one I wonder if maybe
if they hadn't do it the Holy Trinity
actually three on a match um I'm just
talking with this three three three yeah
it pretty probably like a seven so you
said that that would be a good it would
be a good omen but it's usually not it's
usually bad it's usually bad all right
now three on a match they say if you
light three people's cigarettes with a
match that's very bad luck now they
think Norwalk Crimean War okay snipers
yeah that's exactly why yeah yep because
you light the thing and they see you
sniper and then you like the second one
and they aim yeah it takes about that
along and then the third one is you're
the one that's gonna get it there's also
and this might stem from a similar thing
but there's actually a more recent one
that if you have a photograph of three
people than the one in the middle is
gonna die first
that's another one I can too like
leaving the funeral firs no
can we not be in the middle can one of
us be on someone's shoulder you know is
this gonna work yeah in other words you
can't take a photo of three people only
two or four yeah you can't ever have an
odd number you can't ever have an odd
number this is very funny
actually if you believed all of these
you would never be able to do anything
ever now that's what happens those
people have bad really bad OCD yeah they
just have to stay in the house and just
not step on a crack it's just not touch
touch anything and and think certain
orders of numbers constantly in order to
erase the yeah the the bad luck sin I
don't know what you call it the mental
glitch in your head you have to erase
that and actually that's that's actually
really insightful of you to say that
because I think everyone has some level
mmm a visit because that's a natural
that's a natural way that human mind
works so you can see that that's just a
really over exaggeration of the same
kind of thing that everyone has like
that kind of magical thinking that that
causation yeah like where you think well
this happened because of this rather
than just this happened after this and
didn't have anything to do with it
because people want causality they want
to plot they want you know there isn't
really but you know everybody wants that
it's very natural now here's another
thing there is a lot a lot of death
omens and bad luck symbols symbolism
about birds and probably this and about
bats too to a lesser extent but probably
because I guess two ancient peoples
birds seemed like messengers of the gods
because like they could they could fly
so they were always up in the heavens
and whatnot cermagic yeah so so there's
a lot of things about birds being you
know death portents of death yeah I
think it's like what happened to the
heavens and they can fly down from the
heavens and the heavens yeah so you
could see how that could happen so
pretty much you know there's certain
species of birds that have more legends
about them than others but pretty much
any bird flying into the door of the
window or your house or even just
staring in the window from outside or
tapping on the glass that means that
someone in the house is going to die
yeah because they've come to get you I
guess fan of the show just had that
happen really yeah
took a video up and showed it to me and
I said now don't worry about it you
knows who he is not imagine oh my god
I'd be alright dude this yeah it's okay
because here's the thing like we used to
worry store didn't die bird live the
bird lived well yeah okay they found the
bird senseless underneath the window
yeah yeah well that used to happen the
office I used to work at had those
reflective windows so we had that [ __ ]
happen all the time pretty much every
other day would be like [ __ ] yeah pigeon
flying into there are birds also there's
a lot a lot of death omens stuff about
owls because they're not turn old big
and they're predatory I guess hi guys we
have one lives in our backyard yeah
which which is bad luck we're moving all
the time yeah um but if you see an owl
during the day that's very bad luck as
does hearing one hoot which is done
because they heard all the time yeah I
mean you know um also crows and ravens
now crows and ravens if you see a group
of two three or four of them that's good
luck okay however if you see one that's
bad luck if you see five that means
you're gonna get sick if you see six
that means you're dead so there's even
like a little like rhyme about it but uh
also a magpie if he if he stares at you
yeah that means you're gonna die a
person who is lying in bed and I do not
remember the omen yeah
the Raven never in the first Olman Oh
Ronnie I forgot all about that have to
check that I forgot all about that um
oh yeah the only pulled out the eyes of
uh was it the mom or was it who they
were even pulling out the axe yeah Jenny
pull out the eyes of the mom was she
wrecked the car and then she got
attacked by Raven in the almond what she
didn't die like that
oh she's got ice the mom she somebody
got her eyes pulled out in there when
she was hitting to be hit by a truck in
the road remember was that the was that
the who was that
are you sure that was the oven pretty
sure maybe wrong anyway no no I can't
remember I haven't seen her in such a
long time okay so if you're laying in
bed and you hear the call of the first
cuckoo of the year which I don't know if
you would no no it was the first one but
I guess the first one you heard from
your corner from your point of view and
you'd be like [ __ ] yeah that means
you're gonna die too also seeing two
turtledoves in a tree outside um if a
sparrow throws a swallow out of its nest
that means a son will be born but a
daughter will die
how do you know that this even happens
happen did you sit around and like I
said see me like I said a lot of these
are like pretty general you're like yeah
I can see why they thought that rough
but ones like this that are so specific
yeah it's like did just one person see
that happen or did one person like write
that into a fictional story I like as a
symbol and then people picked up on it
without me because one that's not
specific yeah that had to come from just
one person somebody made that up because
that can't have happened often enough
for it to become a meme for yeah to
become an idea that spread like that was
something from a book yeah I bet you
that's what I'm that's my theory and I'm
sticking to it
also woodpecker's knocking on the window
also very bad luck which you know that's
what kind of what they do so I don't
know
also you should never bring peacock
feathers wait a minute wait wait a
minute
a woodpecker knocking on the window yeah
think about this
how could when a woodpecker knocks on a
tree he's gripping the tree with yes
claws and pecking on it
yeah how could he grip glass well he
doesn't have to sit he could be sitting
on the sill give me sit on the cylinders
yeah okay just any bird could do that
that's what I mean all right I don't
know why they mentioned like they call
that specific because you're pretty much
any bird tapping on your window like hey
yeah I'm coming for which we've had that
happens people sandhill cranes tap and
the windows trying to get oh my god they
just knocked on the door right by my
office the other day we have a we have a
little back door with a little like
window in it and all I heard the others
say it was loud there big dirty but I
was like who's not good at the back that
we never used that door and that I
opened it there's two sandhill cranes
standing there like feet ice yeah if
they ever get any food from you they'll
remember and they'll come back they just
yeah these they're like the Mafia of the
bird Kingdom yeah and I need you okay
they did need one group and another yeah
how do they know they bring their little
families then they come by your house
for a shakedown yeah and then they'll
they'll sit outside and yell really loud
until you like bring food out anybody
from Florida knows this yeah yeah okay
so other than birds there are also a lot
about other kinds of animals black cats
obviously I've always been although in
Egypt they were considered good luck
actually they were probably considered
good luck up until about 17th century
and then for some reason they started
getting associated with witchcraft yeah
in Europe I know yours yeah as much as
familiars now now what a lot of people
don't know is that white rabbits are
also considered to have a lot of the
same superstitions around them as black
cats do I'll tell you if they're
pregnant yeah they'll turn up in a pod
that Glenn Close kills or puts her there
in the bunny boiler just watches them
about fatal attraction the other day
good maybe you guys if you haven't seen
it also there's some about bees if you
look at your window and see bees
swarming around a rotting tree on your
property or if bees swarm your house
which obviously you're kind of [ __ ]
then that kind of sucks that also means
someone in the house is going to die a
black cat meowing at midnight if a black
cat crosses a railroad track one of the
railroad workers will die the next day
that's a bummer yeah so that's
everyone's pretending they didn't see it
did you see a blighted see [ __ ] I know
I'm sure it had like some white patches
on it wasn't a black cat yeah don't
worry about now if it's like I said
since there were something about birds
are a couple about bats as well if the
bat flies into your house and then it
gets away someone in the house will die
so it means you gotta kill it you've got
to kill the bad guys please don't kill
bats you guys bats are adorable it's
just a superstition it's not true yeah I
know cuz you know I know a lot of people
are eat dad about bats but I love that
so that's awesome I think they're
adorable and they're just a little dirty
though oh there's no dirtier than some
people I know hate mosquitoes
yeah and mosquitoes do suck seriously
you can kill mosquitoes if you want
[ __ ] encephalitis and malaria spread
and NASA they're not as dirty as myself
all right yeah a rash or cockroaches for
Christ's sake yeah well well they're
dirty cockroaches if dirty but they
don't care they can survive anything
well yeah you ever heard of a dog of a
cockroach hit the second die I've never
heard of it like you don't live long
enough I don't know yeah I'm not sure
I'm not sure how long they live they
only live a few months right there are
Hardy [ __ ] too though I have
dropped a dictionary on one before then
I picked the dictionary up and he was
still like friggin
if they were only a little bit bigger
we'd be screwed imagine if a cockroaches
were three feet long damn oh don't make
me imagine that oh my god I would just
kill myself I did I can't deal with that
kind of I don't even I'm scared of what
their topic I just would take over and
that's I don't think I'm not even scared
of spiders really or anything like that
but cockroaches freak me the [ __ ] out
and I'm from Florida they fly it's not
funny you guys I know no one ever comes
in the house and they do come underneath
the doors it's it's me I'm the one that
has to go chase it down
she's totally useless she'll be hiding
in the bed yeah I'm just like no nope
nope no and I'm in my underwear trying
to yeah three inch long Florida
cockroach that can fly and they kind of
yes they rear up and look at you they do
that's what I mean they're almost like
their little gangsters yeah and it
everyone can spray him and spray him and
they're they suck I don't I wonder where
there's no death omens about [ __ ]
to make one up and I'm gonna spread it
around okay there's a couple more about
animals dog howling with its head
lowered which you don't usually see cuz
usually they put their heads back if a
dog is howling outside your window that
also means you're gonna die rats leaving
a house I guess that's the same thing as
rats jumping off a ship that's gonna
sink rats running out of a house
suddenly right that means shits about to
something Bad's gonna give in the rats
know what's goin down
yeah they're like somebody's dying in
here out although you think if people
were dying in there they'd be like hey
free mail
I think rats leaving that leaving a
house has to do with fires yeah yeah
yeah house start catches on fire the
rather rather the first rebound to smell
it no way yeah yeah oh that's good yeah
that's good
also this one's kind of cute a groundhog
coming to your house that's a death omen
really like does he come to your housing
hey I can't picture it big how cute that
is that was that could only happen out
in the country - farmhouse yeah little
groundhog coming in the door and then
everyone is that just flipping the [ __ ]
out it was yeah also bad also bad is a
white moth getting into your house there
are also some about plants and trees
same so you know nature kind of stuff if
a rose grows in your house one that made
you need to clean your [ __ ] house
because either price but that also means
that a death in the house is coming if
you this is another real specific one if
you planted a cedar tree in your yard
and it dies but it has to die when the
branches this from my understanding when
the branches are far enough off the
ground that it's like coffin-sized so
like I guess about six feet the size of
a person if it dies then then there'll
be a death in the family also very
specific [ __ ] that and why a cedar
trans-pacific Lee I don't know I'll say
your nose maybe that's what they make
coffins out that's yeah that's the only
thing I could think of yeah that's the
only thing yeah okay that makes sense
cuz it's like oh it looks oh it's enough
for a coffin now yeah yeah and then it
died so that means now it's gonna be
your coffee
you figured that one out let's cuz I'm
insane crazy people think also you're
not supposed to move a cedar tree
I guess presumably if it's alive or dead
yeah
also if a peach tree blooms early also a
death omen okay now there are a lot
about mirrors also well that makes sense
now that comes from capturing people's
spirits yeah now what a lot of people
know is um probably no in Jewish
tradition when someone dies you know
part of the mourning process you put to
cover up all the mirrors in the house
now that is not necessarily a
supernatural thing in that tradition um
from what I read it looks like it's more
a symbolic gesture that I'm not focusing
on myself
we're focusing on mourning the dead
person which you know makes a lot of
sense so it's kind of a nice symbolic
gesture or you're signifying your
withdrawal from society for the mourning
period now but in the Victorian era it
was very much a supernatural there was
very much a supernatural background to
the mirror kind of thing it's like you
said they you know because it was it was
almost seen as like a not necessarily
like your doppelganger but like that was
your soul they were saying so so they
said if you like especially when they
kept the corpses in the house during the
Victorian era they say you should never
ever see the corpses reflection in a
mirror because then it would be stuck in
the house be trapped in the glass yeah
so that's why a lot of times they would
cover them up they also said that you
should not look into a mirror while the
corpses in the house or you would see
the ghost of the dead person behind you
unless you wanted to see the ghosts of
the dead person behind you but that's
probably not good I don't understand the
mirror thinks because man I can remember
when I was a kid yeah that was probably
about hey says maybe said between
somewhere between maybe six and eight
that age maybe a little bit younger it's
hard to tell you know consumed memory
how your memory is when you're young but
I ended up getting a mirror for my mom
it was kind of like a travel mirror
maybe about ten inches by 10 inches and
I was playing with and I looked into the
mirror and I said I wonder what this
mirror would look like in the other
so I went in to I think it was one of
the bedrooms my mom's bedroom they had
like a mirror in front of the dresser
right yeah and I line them up and look
at the mirror in the mirrors reflection
and of course it looks like an endless
purchase yeah and that just I can
remember being a little kid how that
blew me away yeah
damn it goes on forever what if I can go
in there yeah and then I was thinking
what if something came out of there
right there is that yeah and so just
that little bit of magical thinking when
you're a little kid I could see how in
people that you know are kind of
ignorant would be tripped out yeah yeah
well and you can see it I mean even
nowadays look at how many horror movies
use that trope of somebody shaving and
then they suddenly get up in the middle
there's something behind that and for
years after that really and you know I
grew up in the seventies here this is
the modern age yeah I'd be afraid to
wake up in the middle of night and go
bathroom you know kid and afraid to
catch a glimpse of myself in there he's
in the dark
yeah and that's still and I am NOT
superstitious at all yeah but every but
you still kind of yeah I mean how many
people even if they say they're not
superstitious how many people have the
balls to go in a dark bathroom all by
themselves close the door yeah and say
like bloody moderator Candy Man or
really did any of you have the balls to
do that I know it is kind of like if you
see catch your reflection in a mirror at
night in the dark there is kind of a
sense of having another person in the
room in the room with you yeah like
which is probably what it is to say yeah
it's you know it is but yeah it's just
your instincts playing tricks with you
yeah that's something next to you
because I mean still as modern as we are
nowadays our brains are still kind of
closed or they're very primitive so you
know all you can do is kind of just know
and even if you intellectually know that
that's why then it's still kind of you
know so obviously breaking a mirror
always bad luck although specifically
although specifically breaking a mirror
portends death for the eldest son in the
also you should never let a baby look
into the mirror before its first
birthday oh hell no or they or they will
have an early death that's not specific
about how early the death is like maybe
they'll die when they're 18 or somebody
knows oh they'll die at 60 instead of 65
yeah it's like one of the parameters
here well they were gonna live five
years longer but you know they looked in
that mirror when they are a baby and
they [ __ ] it all up
all right so I'm gonna take another real
quick break right now and then we will
come back and talk a little bit more
about it and fart around spar go to WWE
us are Chamath on for the Jenny Ashford
author page okay now aside from the
obvious mirrors there are also a lot of
probably just as obvious ones about
clocks now for a long time it's been a
tradition if someone died in the house
that you stopped all the clocks in the
house or at least the ones in the room
with them and I think that was more like
a signifier that that person's time had
come to an end but there are also some
superstitions about it like if the head
of the household dies and you don't stop
the clocks then everybody else in the
house will died say Oh hmm I'm not sure
why and if a clock that was in the house
with a dead person like ran down then
you would never get it to work again
like even if you wound it so it breaks
the clock yeah it breaks the clock I
don't believe that yeah I don't think
they believe that yeah you can find just
prove that and real quick wonder how
that became a that's what I mean it's
like a clock let's see if that works and
then I'm like oh wow that's myth busted
yeah but yeah they didn't have
Mythbusters back then um also they said
don't but don't start the clock back
until after the dead person is buried
okay so after they're buried it's okay I
get it yeah
in also if a clock that's been broken or
hasn't been running if it suddenly
strikes or if it strikes thirteen hey
like our show yeah you know
hey plug even though you're already
listening to commercial run commercial
for the show your next week on 13
o'clock but yeah so for clock strikes 13
obviously that's a your clocks [ __ ] up
but yeah that's a death element too and
there are ones about other household
objects as well there's a lot of one
about brooms weirdly um pretty common in
some parts of the world but you need to
buy a new broom like you can't bring
your old broom from your old house to
the new house with you because I guess
it all the spirits there stuck to your
broom will come to the new house of you
so you have to buy a new one and um also
but if there's a corpse in the house
once again but Han said you know the
about the broom yeah reminds me of a
Japanese superstition what's that
okay well the Japanese thought the
longer that you had an item like so you
had an item in your house for a long
period of time but there's a risk
there's a chance that that item could
come to life yeah become sentient and
one of the things that they were that
was expensive in a common Japanese house
didn't see like the Tokugawa period you
know you talk about 1700s 1800s you know
around that time one of the most
expensive things that would be in a
average Japanese house would be an
umbrella
it is pretty umbrellas that yeah they
kept him for a long time so there was
this constant Japanese fear that an
umbrella might come come to life and
they believe in a thing called an
umbrella monster yeah these umbrellas
came to life they grew I have a mouth on
them they could fly and one bike and one
foot and I believe that I believe that
they could shoot poison our town their
mouth or they go there because of course
they can cuz of course it's like a
[ __ ] Japanese monster when you you
know we you'll show a picture of this
monster it's I don't remember the name
of it in Japanese but it translates to
umbrella monster I saw a Japanese
monster movie when I was a little kids
in California on on channel 22 you
remember him and had the old UHF
channels yeah and that was the Japanese
American Channel and it was the scariest
monster movie for me was a little kid
umbrellas running around spitting poison
darts at people just terrified me if I
were to saw it today if I were to see it
today it would probably absolutely
ridiculous it was funny you know prior
to prom
I didn't know what I was looking at it I
didn't realize that this was supposed to
be happening in the past and why do
these guys have sorts you know you know
what are the torches for where are the
lights I didn't realize that they were
portraying you know this happening now
when did this happen
no [ __ ] is going on why did the
umbrellas have eyes you know man scare
me
although is about six six years old
probably well since we're on that topic
you guys should see the yokai monster
yes
trilogy yeah cuz that [ __ ] is it has it
has other monsters too but it also has
an umbrella but really the best one is
the first one the first one it's called
yokai wars and it called spook warfare
boot warfare yeah yokai monsters yes
right yokai monka monsters lupus for
warfare yeah it's a trilogy but really
the first one is the most batshit so
yeah that's the bet crazy well made and
well written funny and yeah well it's
kind of creepy yeah I mean like in an
eerie unsettling way just because the
monsters are so bizarre the monsters are
weird and bizarre and you and as a
westerner you will not recognize or
understand who these monsters are one of
them is a kapa yeah the main characters
a kapa and a cop ISM is kind of like the
Japanese version of The Creature from
the Black Lagoon yeah he's like a
salamander designed based on Jenna
a giant salamander on a Japanese giant
salamander which is not a fictional
creature they really do exist and some
of them can get to be like 4 or 5 feet
long
yeah they're pretty freaky yeah and the
nasty bite and the Japanese had all
these tails that they would come out of
water and get the kids
yeah and kill kids which they maybe they
did that's what I'm thinking of they're
big enough to take a salamander yeah
yeah Oh Jeremy Wade goes and catches one
yeah that's right and they all River
Monsters out of the episode on that and
they're aggressive yeah they got a hold
of your hand they take the other yeah so
you could totally see that happening the
kapa kapa yeah and he has kind of a flat
head yeah like like you could sit a vase
on it or something yeah see spook
warfare it's a good one yeah it is very
funny you can get I think we just got a
right Amazon or Ebay or whatever no we
bought the DVD yeah we yeah I don't
think he can rent it you have to buy it
yeah okay
they weren't that expensive though
wasn't okay yeah okay so what was that
I'm out brooms okay so uh
if you sweep a house before the corpse
is taken out of the house that means the
person sweeping will die next also a
dish or glass breaking when no one is
near it signifies the death in the
family which you would think it
signified a poltergeist infestation or
this glass flying off the [ __ ] [ __ ]
also if you're doing a toast you know
with glasses and the glass breaks during
the toast and the person being toasted
will die also same thing if a portrait
falls off a wall meaning that the person
in the portrait is going to die and this
one I thought this one was kind of
interesting and I'd never heard this one
before
you know when the candles burning and
the wax drips down the side yeah they
call that the shroud that wax that's
dripping down the end out the shroud is
aiming toward you if it starts dripping
toward you that means you're gonna die
nice because it's like a death shroud or
the other person [ __ ] you Joe sorry Joe
dropping an umbrella on the floor means
there will be a murder in the house huh
there are a lot of ones about umbrellas
like I said we were just talking about
the Japanese are I mean obviously they
have the ones about don't open that
doesn't mean you're gonna die Sara Lee
yeah but it's just general bad luck if
you open one in the house which I guess
it might have been back in the old days
because because the you know the [ __ ]
the you know the umbrella is made out of
you know if you open in the hash gonna
folks on this [ __ ] on I have you know
so you can see where that kind of came
from um also there are some there a few
like about food and stuff like that like
you know bowl of salt on a corpses chest
keep the evil spirits away I guess keep
the evil spirits from reanimating the
corpse I suppose or or whatever if
you're drinking a cup of coffee and you
get to the bottom and there are coffee
grounds in the bottom that look like a
coffin obviously not good that's kind of
like a tea leaf nestlings coffin with it
I guess
well you know if you kind of squint it
looks like it's just a smudge you know
if a loaf of bread splits across the top
like completely across the top while
being baked or if you slice the loaf of
bread and find a big air pocket in there
yeah then that's also a deaf element
you're gone and they said and I think
that one's from England because if the
air pocket is big and it's like because
it's like a little coffin
okay like I said so you can see right at
these space yeah that's like the empty
space where your coffin is so I can so I
can see that one there is also the the
very famous one about thirteen people
sitting down for a meal yeah means that
one of them will die usually the last
one to arrive now a lot of people think
that this comes from the Christian the
Christian tradition of the Last Supper
and Judas and blah-dee blah-blah but
it's actually older than that they think
it actually comes from norse mythology
all right because the twelve gods were
dining at Valhalla okay and then Loki
shows up and [ __ ] everything up and
they're a big fight and one of the
best-loved gods Balor is killed in the
ensuing melee Wow
so third - so the 13th person showing up
to a party is always the party the
bummer I mean someone's shits gonna go
down someone's gonna die so or sometimes
it's the person who gets up from the
table first will be the next to die also
if a piece of meat falls out of your
mouth that means in the family that's
not good for me because I'm like not a
really good I have food falling I'm a
know so that's probably not good there
also some about astronomical signs and
weather and things like that like
children born during a comet will die
young a meteor falling on the house
pretends death for someone within
especially if the meteor falls on their
head I would imagine seeing a shooting
star that also means a death in your
family or seeing a rainbow bending over
your house Wow or the Sun looking
blood-red at sunset which is which it
usually does seeing a bit rainbow bend
over your house it would be possible you
just walk around the house and get the
angle that's what I mean wherever you
were there's a rainbow you could get
your house underneath it it's kind of
like the Star of Bethlehem flying over
and showing showing the Weizmann where
the baby Jesus was a whole lot I'm like
where were you what were you talking
about yeah yeah that made no sense ever
made sense to me I'm sorry no it doesn't
make any sense they were they were
challenging I challenge you to go out in
the nighttime sky and try to find a star
that
find support yeah yeah that's the
[ __ ] they were following their GPS
that's one they just happen to like
wander crime there's gonna be relative
to the ground the stars are moving all
night maybe maybe a meteor fell into the
stable I think there but I think what
they're trying to describe actually
there was something kind of like a UFO
bright light comes down and lands on the
top of the house to show them where it
is so anything on top of the house those
aliens it's like aliens okay well
honestly wait that finger of even though
that whole story is [ __ ] from top to
bottom yeah I think it's astrological is
what I think a metaphor it's a metaphor
for an astrological event something that
was yet something even though that story
didn't happen right like I think when it
was written I think that's what I meant
that it was an astronomical event also
dreams these are particular dreams that
if you have that are death omens if you
dream of a white horse or a white swan
there will be a death in your family
also if you dream of your teeth falling
out
and that's the witan and they're coming
out like Rosic or yeah yeah I see now
like you cut the cut off the coins
probably now the dream isn't the same
it's usually like an aspect of just some
other random dream and I want to sudden
your teeth they'll start falling out
yeah and from what I like I used to
think it was really weird but now this
is like one of the top ten most common
dreams I think it has to do with like
your putt it's a powerless feeling like
maybe that's what it is because for me
evolutionary record is gone yeah from an
evolutionary standpoint yeah if you lost
your teeth you wouldn't be able to eat
yeah you know I mean you couldn't defend
yourself you could eat that's well so
you would die so yeah that's probably
what it is impotency yeah it's a
throwback to your lizard brain kind of
thing it's probably cuz everyone I have
talked to has had dreams at some point
of their teeth between that ball and I
have had many like that
also if you dream of helping someone get
dressed weirdly enough if you're walking
through muddy water if you look up in
the sky and see more than one moon
then you are in Star Wars or you're
going to die yeah you're you're on also
if you dream of old shoes dreaming of a
coffin means you will marry rich but die
young okay also very specific and a few
other ones that were just kind of random
and didn't go in with any of the other
themes obviously seeing your
doppelganger that's never a good thing
and I think even Edgar Allan Poe wrote a
story about that William what was that
called I can't remember it happens and
I'm not too lazy looking I'm sorry if
you see your shadow without a head well
if you see your shadow and don't have a
gun on it yeah that's something somebody
made up that would be pretty freaky
where's my head okay I don't know you
got the angle right you might look like
your head the head of yours that's what
I'm thinking somebody just saw it from a
weird angle I'm like holy [ __ ] yeah it's
just cut it's kind of like now this was
in the omen where they were taking
pictures of people and there was that
black smudge like showing how you were
gonna get killed like that one priest
that got impaled by that [ __ ] that fell
off the top of the church when women
remember I was talked about the oven and
the in the crow came down yes woman's
eyes out director card yeah wasn't that
Damian's grandma he means grandma what
it we're gonna have to see that movie
again I for some reason I've drawn a
total blank oh boy you're sure I just
remember her wandering out into the
street and her eyes are torn out and a
big semi semi tractor-trailer comes up
runs her over she can't see it
see I don't remember that cuz Damien's
mom remember he was riding the tricycle
and knocked her off the knocked her off
the thing and that didn't kill her but
then she went to the hospital and then
mrs. Baylock came and pushed her out the
window well which woman got her eyes
scratched out and then she got hit by a
car that's what I'm trying to think yeah
but I can't think of another woman I
can't think of another woman she was
wearing black maybe did mrs. Baylock die
on that [ __ ] I thought we just saw that
recently why can't I remember god I'm
getting old yeah
I can't rubber [ __ ] anymore also if you
see a headless dog or a spectral black
dog I'm speaking of the omen that's also
very bad or if you see a shadow person
or a woman in white that's obviously not
just a living person
now seeing the spirit of a living person
is an omen that they'll die but only if
you can't clearly see their face like if
their face is blurry if you can see
their face that means they're dead
already huh good um
now some cultures actually say that
seeing the spirit of living person is
actually a good thing if they're walking
towards you that's a good thing that
means that person is healthy and in good
health or whatever but if they're
walking away from you that's bad and
like I said we get into the hearse thing
again it's like once they passes you
it's like you know what I mean so uh
yeah in Scotland seeing the spirit of a
living person in the morning means that
person will have a long healthy life but
seeing in the evening means they're
going to die soon and there's also one
this is kind of like a wedding one but
if a seamstress is working on a wedding
dress and she pricks her finger and gets
blood on the dress that means the bride
is dead it's going to die um so actually
oh [ __ ] okay so we're coming up to an
hour now so I guess we will wrap it up
so that's pretty much all them anyway um
yeah I think I kind of went through most
of my ones I might skip some but you
know and there's tons of other ones so
it's a fun show yeah and like I said you
know it's our 13th episode so we wanted
to kind of do something in that vein um
got some good guests lined up or plan to
be lined up soon yeah Steve marrow is
one of them the other one I'm not going
to mention yes to early yeah we have
Steve Merrill and parapsychologist we
have them on soon yeah that'll be cool
and also I mentioned it last week but we
have t-shirts t-shirts t-shirts yeah
five different designs um go to
zazzle.com
thirteen o'clock and you can see the
shirts there I'll be putting up other
ones you know if should be in the
description box dude yes as the time
goes on I'll be putting up new ones but
there's five kind of cool ones up there
right now and as usual you know all
designed by Jenny yes I designed all of
them I'm also a graphic designer among
many other things that I do so um also
we mentioned it last week but hopefully
the transition will be very done soon
too over to project Entertainment
Network so hopefully all the links will
be working and all that other kind of
man that's really cool now because I
think one person complained that they
that they couldn't get last week's show
on project entertainment cuz but you
know we're still going through some
and as a conversion problem yeah it's a
conversion process that it should be the
old links from Project I radio are going
to be broken as a December first and it
should all be over to project
entertainment network by then so I hope
you enjoyed the show and remember to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
follow us on Facebook and Twitter at 13
o'clock podcast and anything else you'd
like to say Thomas mr. bald now I'm just
missing here let's shine it is shine
look at it sure
night ride use a little foo man she
looks just like Ming the Merciless
oh my god you should do that or Anton
LaVey also you need I don't know about
all about me you need a house or
something or some devil wants would be
gone does it have to be surgically
implanted to look cool okay alright
where's the little 666 in your head I
have to see that okay it's not there you
guys he's not the Antichrist alright
we'll see you next week bye
you